SPEAKER 1: Matthew Mehan is the
Director of Academic Programs
and the Worsham Teaching Fellow
at Hillsdale College's Kirby
Center in Washington, DC.
He earned his PhD at the
University of Dallas,
where he wrote a dissertation
on Shakespeare's vision
for leadership education in
his collaborative play Sir
Thomas More.
Dr. Mehan has been a Publius
Fellow at the Claremont
Institute, and is a Fellow
of the Center for Thomas More
Studies, and a reader
at the Folger Library.
He has served as a
speechwriter and communications
consultant for civic
leaders around the country.
He is the author of Mr.
Mehan's Mildly Amusing Mythical
Mammals, an illustrated
book of poems.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Matthew Mehan.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW MEHAN:
Thank you very much.
Applied mathematics,
it's awesome.
I hear it's a lit talk.
I guess Matt Bell has a sense
of humor to pair us together,
but that's good.
That's the liberal arts.
Thank you all for coming.
Thank you, Matt Bell, for
shepherding me out here.
And thank you all
for your support
of Hillsdale, particularly
our new venture,
which I've been a part
of out in Washington, DC,
the Steve and Amy Van Andel
Graduate School of Government.
I got the unbelievable honor to
teach the very first classes,
very first classes, very
first class this fall.
And it was just wonderful.
We started with Antigone,
and the Book Of Proverbs,
and Aristotle's
Nicomachean Ethics.
And it's happening
right on Capitol Hill.
And it's been a really
great honor in my life.
So thank you all for
supporting Hillsdale.
[APPLAUSE]
Before I speak directly
about Thomas More's Utopia,
I'd like to start with three
jokes about Marxist socialists,
but I repeat myself.
[LAUGHTER]
From the satirical humor
site McSweeney's, usually
left leaning, but nevertheless--
see if you can spot what
all three of the jokes
have in common.
The first one-- knock, knock.
Who's there?
A Marxist socialist.
A Marxist socialist who?
A Marxist socialist who wants to
give you a pamphlet about class
struggle.
I'll try another one, sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
What did one Marxist
socialist say to another?
Like you, I also advocate
a proletarian revolution
culminating in
collective ownership.
Last one, bear with me.
What do you get when you cross
a Marxist with a socialist?
Two people who generally feel
that the value of a commodity
is equal to its socially
necessary labor time.
They're great fun at parties.
I think that's
the takeaway here.
[LAUGHTER]
What the humorist at
McSweeney's is getting at
is what the famous German
socialist Friedrich
Engels knew as a distinct
trait of German socialists,
where all this sort of began.
In the introduction to his
English edition of Socialism--
Utopian and Scientific-- and
there he's borrowing from
the word coined by
Thomas More there--
which is a collected series
of-- shocker-- pamphlets--
by the way, they're
great fun at parties.
They give you pamphlets.
Poor Friedrich seems defensive
before his witty English
audience when he writes this.
"As is well known, we Germans
are of a terribly ponderous
grundlichkeit."
OK.
Radical profundity, or
profound radicality,
whatever you may
like to call it.
When you learn
that grundlichkeit
basically means thoroughness--
that's all it means--
the next line becomes
unintentionally hilarious.
Engels continues to
expound thoroughly
on the meaning of
thoroughness this way--
"Whenever any one
of us expounds what
he considers a new
doctrine, he has first
to elaborate it into an
all-compromising system.
He has to prove that both
the principles of logic
and the fundamental
laws of the universe
had existed from all
eternity for no other purpose
than to ultimately
lead to this newly
discovered crowning theory."
And it gets even
more ridiculous after
that when this father of modern
German socialism we find out
was trying to satirize
another socialist.
And after going through
another page of this,
he says finally, with a little
grundlichkeit of his own,
"Anyhow, the systematic
comprehensiveness
of my opponent gave
me the opportunity
of developing in opposition
to him and in a more connected
form than had
previously been done
the views held by
Karl Marx and myself
on this great
variety of subjects."
Like I said, Thanksgiving
dinner just isn't the same
without Uncle Friedrich arguing
with good old cousin Mr.
Professor Dr. E. Duhring.
This is how they speak.
They speak heavy, ponderous
monologues, massive systems.
It's not a witty group.
In short, German socialists
are not known for their wit.
And Friedrich Engels
knew it well enough
to be sheepish about it before
the witty British audience he
was seeking to
persuade in that essay.
Without arguing here,
permit me to assert
that a people tend to be
witty if they've been led so
by the witty examples of their
famous writers, speakers,
their poets, historians,
and statesmen,
and if they're very fortunate,
even their philosophers.
Not incidental to our
purpose today, Thomas More
was all of these things.
But let me be more thorough and
give you the testimony of one
of More's own contemporaries.
"Thomas More is a man of
an angel's wit and singular
learning.
He is a man of many
excellent virtues.
I know not his
fellow, for where is
the man in whom
is so many goodly
virtues, of that gentleness,
lowliness, and affability,
and as time requires, a
man of marvelous mirth,
and pastimes, and sometimes
of steadfast gravity,
a man for all seasons."
Those were the words of
Robert Whittington, who
was a liberal arts teacher
and translator of Cicero
and Seneca, two Roman
philosopher statesman orders
deeply favored by
Thomas More and featured
in More's most famous and
famously misunderstood Utopia.
The phrase "man for all
seasons" suits more well,
so well that it became the
hallmark of the 20th century
understanding of him.
In his lifetime,
More was speaker
of the House of Commons.
And while he was speaker
of the House of Commons,
he secured the first
right of free speech--
not for the whole of London
or the whole of England,
but just for the
Parliament so they
could speak freely to the king
without risking their lives.
He was also the Lord Chancellor
of England, stepping up,
as Shakespeare put it, up nearly
to his country's head, right
below the King, essentially
effectively running
the government for him.
And he was a famous poet,
historian, and essayist,
as well as a brilliant lawyer,
and an attentive father.
And after his
execution and death,
More was praised before
Queen Elizabeth--
that's Henry VIII's
father, whom he opposed--
and the entire
Parliament at St. Paul's
Cathedral in Shakespeare's
time, and named
a saint of both the Anglican
and Catholic churches
in our own time.
That, to me, is sort of
the great combo trick.
I don't know how you do
that, the Church of England
and the Roman Church.
But anyway, all of these
impressive achievements
of More aside, in 1954 the
playwright Robert Bolt wrote
A Man For All
Seasons, about More's
artful and courageous resistance
to King Henry VIII, who
violated the Magna Carta
and his coronation oath
in order to divorce
his wife and declare
himself the head of
both church and state.
More's refusal to accept this
Caesar opapism of King Henry
landed More in the
Tower of London and then
on the chopping block.
Likewise, it is that
same stalwart objection
by More to the combination
of state and church authority
that sent the Puritan
pilgrims to Plymouth
and the Catholic
pilgrims to Maryland.
The film version of
Man For All Seasons
won eight Academy
Awards in 1967,
including Best
Picture and Director.
And in 1990, the Law
Society of Great Britain
named him Lawyer
of the Millennium.
And Pope John Paul II named
him the Patron of Statesmen
for the Catholic
Church worldwide.
Despite all these
various accolades
and honors over the
centuries, despite being
a principal source of a
number of Shakespeare's plays,
despite being considered by
Jonathan Swift to be, quote,
"the person of the
greatest virtue
these islands ever produced,"
it is nevertheless true
what Robert Bolt
More's character
says to a simple-minded
Spaniard diplomat
when he presumes to
know what More thinks
about the politics of the day.
The Spaniard-- (SPANISH
ACCENT) "But your views,
Sir Thomas More,
are well known,"
which More contradicts, saying,
"My views are much guessed at."
So too today, with careless,
unhistorical, and confusing
melodramas like HBO's The
Tudors, and BBC's Wolf Hall,
More's view remains much
guessed at, but still
very poorly known.
And that's especially
true when it
comes to his most complex
and confounding ironic work,
Utopia, written 1560, published
throughout the continent,
and England, and wildly
popular from the start.
I mean, it was the book
of Europe at the time.
We have Hunger Games,
they had Utopia,
sort of a different world.
[LAUGHTER]
More makes himself a character
in the dialogue of Utopia,
along with his friend and fellow
Christian humanist Peter Giles.
But it's a tricky dialogue that
has within it both a monologue
about a different dialogue
from before the dialogue
and a different monologue
within the dialogue
that's longer than the rest
of the entire dialogue,
except that the monologue
is technically a very
long part of the dialogue.
That's a little
grundlichkeit for you.
[LAUGHTER]
The two major
monologues in Utopia
are given by the
third interlocutor
in the dialogue, a strange
and passionate character.
He's a traveler and scholar
named Raphael Hythloday,
who claims to have lived on
the amazing island of Utopia--
which means no
place, by the way--
and with its novel
and he says, "truly
excellent political
institutions."
The text of Utopia is
divided into two books,
and Raphael Hythloday
dominates both of them.
Book two of Utopia
is almost exclusively
Raphael's long and
extremely thorough account
of the laws, habits, and
customs of the Utopians.
And even though
book two technically
has More's character
speak at the very end,
it is really Raphael
Hythloday's monologue,
with the other speakers
reduced to mere onlookers.
Hythloday frustrates
any authentic dialogue
at that point.
And I'm kind of
reminded of the bad guy
syndrome from The Incredibles.
You remember that line?
"You sly dog, you
caught me monologuing."
The bad guys in the comic
books are always monologuing
about their evil plans.
There's something about
that in Raphael Hythloday.
He just gets going,
and you can't stop him.
This chronic monologuer's name
means both healer of God--
that's Raphael, Rafael--
and skilled speaker
of nonsense--
hythlodaeus in Greek.
By giving the character
a name like that,
More sets the attentive
reader on guard
to suspect that whatever
Raphael Hythloday is going
to say about this island and
its institutions, Utopia,
you can bet it's going to be a
mixture of sense and nonsense.
And so it is.
But you'd need to have the
wit to see that More is not
being ponderous, literal,
and radical, but rather
witty, ironic, and subtle.
To understand More's
Utopia properly,
the habit of socialist, Marxist,
communist grundlichkeit--
but, again, I repeat myself--
is not very helpful.
Because that cast of mind
and cast of character
only stifles the wit
required to see well
the practical, political,
and actual world
in which we live and work.
Now, I want to take a moment
to apologize for this talk,
because it combines a few
things that don't mix very well.
Presenting a talk on both
heavy and sad socialism,
it's a very grim, dark thing.
Matt Bell's talking about hell.
He sort of set that up for us.
And then we've got to combine
it with More's witty and wise,
mirthful Utopia.
It's like serving a peanut
butter sandwich mixed
with pickled herring or
making a Netflix special
featuring the art of
laughter-- the joy
of laughter and oral surgery.
[LAUGHTER]
Or it's as if you dressed up for
Halloween as someone pretending
to be you.
What?
If you're puzzled at that sort
of ironic and contradictory
humor, where you thought
it was going one way
and it goes another, welcome
to Thomas More's Utopia.
It's a very puzzling book that
gives you the distinct sense
that you are not
always in on the joke,
at least not at first, but that
the humor is, nevertheless,
there to help the reader
to more than just laughs.
In other words, its ironic
jokes are not very socialist.
Because, as we all
know, socialist jokes
are only funny if
everybody gets it.
[LAUGHTER]
Wait for it.
No.
[LAUGHTER]
In fact, Utopia is
so puzzling that it's
been famously nicknamed
the statesman's puzzle.
Yet the book is less
and less puzzling
the wittier and more
ironically humorous
a lens you use to read it.
On the other hand,
Utopia is far more
puzzling for people who have a
bad case of grundlichkeit, that
ponderous seriousness that
can't handle dialogue and double
meaning.
The great critic of
socialism and communism,
Alexander Solzhenitsyn,
put it this way--
"No one would ever
dare accuse Stalin
of having a sense of humor."
[LAUGHTER]
They're not known for
their sense of humor.
With 50 million dead, I
suppose that joke is always
sort of #TooSoon, but they're
dark, deep, serious, grim
fellows.
And More has even famously--
was even famously witty
in the hour of his death.
So here's the difference
between Stalin and More.
Unlike the brutal, humorous,
unfunny, socialist, communist
Stalin--
again, I repeat myself--
who murdered many millions,
the Christian, humanist, poet,
lawyer, statesman
loved to laugh.
He referred to himself
as having the nature
of half a giglet and more.
Do you guys know
what a giglet is?
If you ever go to
Italy or Mexico,
the street vendors will carve
these little wooden dentures.
And the way you open them, they
scrape, and they go wa, wa, wa.
So, it's like a little
laughing denture.
But that's how More referred
to himself in his books,
is I can't stop
laughing, even though I'm
this very serious statesman.
Please don't tickle
my funny bone.
In his lifetime, More was
famous for using humor,
both to mock his opponents--
not always with
sarcasm, mind you--
but very often also
with witty irony
that was difficult to defeat
and that pricked the conscience.
When Sir More rose
to the national stage
as speaker of the House, he
was known as Master Mock.
And More was even
famously witty,
like I said, on the scaffold.
Among other jests, when
rising to the scaffold
and the chopping block, he
joked to his own headsman,
"I pray you, let me lay
my beard over the block,
lest you should cut it.
The reason being, of course,
that my beard has not
offended the king."
This is the moment of death.
More mentioned-- not a
few times, by the way--
in his writings, in his
letters, that his last name
in both Latin and
Greek means fool.
And his first name, Didymus,
Thomas, means twin or double.
Also, it means mulberry,
but that's really neither
here nor there.
After More's death in
the times that followed,
he was honored by Shakespeare
with a very favorable
collaborative play
called Sir Thomas More--
you heard I did my
dissertation on that play--
which Shakespeare co-wrote with
five other popular playwrights
of his day.
So imagine if Spielberg, Nolan--
pick your top-- Lucas--
big, big names-- Whedon--
all got together
and said, OK, we
are going to produce this play.
The censors said,
no, you may not,
because it had a
riot scene, and they
didn't want anyone thinking
about rioting in London.
But it was, nevertheless,
a professionally produced--
or written play by some
of the top playwrights.
More-- I lost my place here.
In it, true to
biographical accounts,
More is completely
serious when he must be--
Quelling a citywide
riot in London
and administering justice for
the realm at the privy council
of the king.
But otherwise he's constantly
dropping witty mocks,
funny puns, and clever
and ironic jokes
for his friends, Desiderius
Erasmus and even very subtly
for his friend King
Henry VIII, always
with an eye to both their
delight and their instruction.
More even stages a humble
little morality play
within the play for his friend
the Lord Mayor of London,
called the Marriage
of Wit and Wisdom.
Indeed throughout the play, More
jests in his witty, wise way,
staging humorous
plays of his own
that contain high moral matter.
For instance, when
imprisoned in the tower
on the eve of execution,
he tells the guard
a low potty humor joke that
has a high and subtle lesson
about tyranny, meant
explicitly for the king,
should he ever hear tell of
it, which More rightly suspects
he will.
As the tower guard
character puts it,
marveling aloud in the
play, "In life and death,
still merry, Sir Thomas More."
In other words, the author
of Utopia knew how to laugh,
how to mock, how to jest, how
to speak doubly and ironically,
even when discussing
serious life and death
matters of political justice.
I've got a little spider here.
Hello, friend.
It's a comic prop--
life and death questions
like justice and tyranny.
He knew how to both
love and mock himself,
his friends, and his king.
By the way, if, as
I will argue here,
More was a proto-Republican
that wanted to see England
move from a monarchy to
a full-blown republic.
You'd better learn how
to make fun of a king
without getting
your head cut off.
How else do you do it short of
murdering your fellow citizens?
But you wouldn't know
More's Utopia holds up
socialists for
ambivalent scrutiny,
ironic mockery, and subtle
correction if you insist
on witlessly viewing the world
through the lens of unironic,
literal-minded,
stripped down, unadorned
socialist grundlichkeit.
For example, if you
took a chilly turn
through the Alexandrovsky
Garden in the Kremlin in Moscow,
you will find a monument, an
ornate obelisk commemorating
the Romanov tsars of
yesteryear, with carved granite
tens of feet tall and shining,
gold-leafed, double-eagle,
pyramidian cap.
The obelisk feels very
tsarist, very ornate,
like those potentates that
share both in sort of the East
and the West that ruled
Russia for hundreds of years.
And yet, it was only
erected in 2013.
Or rather, it was
restored by Putin.
Lenin erased the original,
ordering Soviet riflemen
literally to shoot off the
original commemorative texts
in his 1918 campaign
of Soviet propaganda
shortly after the
Bolshevik Revolution.
Lenin replaced the
old tsarist monument
or really just defaced it with
the brutalist and ponderously
named--
(RUSSIAN ACCENT)
Monument Obelisk
To Outstanding Thinkers and
Personalities of the Struggle
for the Liberation of Workers.
No gold leaf on the Soviet
monument, no double eagle,
just a single,
heavy, cold stone.
I just got bit by a spider.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW MEHAN: That's right.
No.
It's a drone from AOC.
[LAUGHTER]
The Soviet obelisk
was simply a list--
the Soviets liked
keeping lists--
commemorating revolutionary
thinkers and activists
that paved the way for the
Bolsheviks' moment of triumph
and the new socialist era
of glorious transition
to full communism for the
USSR, which stands for,
lest we forget, the Union of
Soviet Socialist Republics.
In the precise middle of
the vertical list of names,
below Karl Marx and our
very thorough friend,
Frederick Engels, and
amidst French anarchists
and German socialist
party leaders,
Lenin and his Soviet
propaganda saw
fit to carve the
name of Thomas More,
no doubt on account of
his famous and famously
misread book, Utopia, and
its fictitious island, which
has abolished private
property and is
said to have neither poverty,
nor envy, nor strife.
Now this stark obelisk, like
so much of Soviet propaganda,
is a lie.
And like the rest of the
Soviet empire's house of lies,
the obelisk was
bulldozed unceremoniously
after communism's fall.
But the lie of More's
Utopia, that it's socialist,
still stands.
If one thoughtlessly skims
Utopia or willfully cherry
picks from its lengthy
and ironic dialogue,
it's possible to think
the author advocates
socialism and the abolition
of private property.
After all, Raphael Hythloday,
the dubious traveler
in the dialogue, who More
compares to the famous liar
Odysseus, does offer the
following lengthy speech.
This is Raphael
Hythloday speaking
at length, grundlichkeit.
"The most prudent man-- that
is Plato in his "Republic--"
easily foresaw that
there could be only one
way to public
well-being, by decreeing
the equality of possessions,
which I do not think
could ever be observed
when individuals
have private ownership.
For when each person, by a
definite right and title"--
remember that-- "sweeps up
as much as can be to himself,
the entire supply of
goods, no matter how large,
is divided up among
only a few persons,
leaving scarcity
for everyone else.
It generally happens then that
each group really deserves
the destiny of the other group,
since the few are rapacious,
shameless, and useless,
while the many, by contrast,
are modest and simple, and
by their daily industry,
more kindly disposed
to the public interest
than they are to themselves.
And this is why I'm fully
persuaded that goods cannot be
distributed in an equitable or
just way or that anything can
turn out well in human affairs
unless ownership is completely
abolished.
And on the other hand,
as long as it remains,
so also will remain an anxiety
producing and inescapable load
of hardships and poverty
for the largest part,
and the best part, by
far, of the human race."
OK.
Long quote, straight
up socialism.
But to think that this
is More's position
or that it is the final verdict
of the dialogue of Utopia
would be like witlessly cherry
picking Macbeth's Act V despair
speech, concluding
that Shakespeare
and the entire
tragedy of Macbeth
agree with the character
Macbeth when he says that "Life
is a tale told by an idiot,
full of sound and fury,
signifying nothing."
Perhaps Macbeth had read
too many socialist pamphlets
that day.
Would the socialist
interpretation
of More's subtle and dialogic
text work less careless
and more, dare I
say it, thorough, we
wouldn't be in this position.
It is perhaps more than
simply an amusing irony
then that the character
of Raphael Hythloday
loves overwhelming
his interlocutors
with very thorough,
very lengthy monologues,
not unlike Friedrich Engels and
his fellow socialist, Dr. E.
Duhring.
Those who think so simply
and simplistically,
as to suggest
seriously and literally
that we ought to remove all
private property to solve
our political ills,
are the same sorts
that can't, for lack of
wit, follow a dialogue
and can't engage in one either.
Like Syndrome from Brad
Bird's Incredibles,
they're too busy monologuing.
Literary wit, listening,
conversing, discerning,
seeing double meaning,
irony, humor, paradox,
the habit of looking at life, at
human behavior, or at the city
and realizing that what's
before your eyes is a tale
told by no idiot,
which signifies
much more than nothing.
But that's the position
of atheist materialism
that undergirds socialism,
is there's nothing but meat
in front of you.
You don't have to
have a double vision.
You don't see the
Providence of God.
You don't see an immortal soul.
You don't see mind,
principle, spirit.
You just see meat on a rock,
hurtling through the dark.
It's a very monologic way
of thinking about the world.
OK.
That was pretty ponderous.
[LAUGHTER]
So these ponderous and
thorough monologuers,
masters of grundlichkeit,
tend to lack the subtlety
and receptivity, that is,
the wit required for wisdom,
for good judgment about
what people say, about texts
that people write, and about
the cities and societies
that we need to build.
That is, the socialist
character type,
which More lampoons in the
person of Raphael Hythloday
in Utopia, tends to have
grundlichkeit when expounding
their own theories of Utopian
and scientific socialism,
but also tend to lack that
same thoroughness when it comes
to being attentive
to reality itself
and what other people
are telling them.
And that reality is that
More's character in Utopia
strongly objects to
Raphael Hythloday's
socialist institutions,
both in book one
and in book two of Utopia.
Here's More's
objection from book one
that he had to wait to give
because Raphael Hythloday went
on and on for a long time
before he could finally
get a word in edgewise
in the dialogue.
"But on the contrary,"
More said, "it seems to me
that life can never be lived
with any convenience, where
all things are owned in common.
For how could there
be a good supply
of things with everybody
trying to get out of work,
not being urged by
the profit motive
and becoming lazy by relying
on the work of others?
But even if they are spurred
to work by the scarcity, when
nobody is able lawfully to
protect as his own what has he
has acquired, is
it not inevitable
that everyone will suffer from
perpetual murder and sedition,
especially when the authority
and reverence of magistrates
is gone?
For how there could be any place
for that when the people cannot
be distinguished among
themselves in any way,
I cannot imagine."
And yet, despite this
very clear counterargument
and others from Thomas
More, the character
in his own dialogue, the bogus
claim that More's Utopia is
really a work of socialist
and communist theory
is still proudly trumpeted,
both from on high
in the ivory tower--
for instance, Cambridge
University's Terry
Eagleton, and from on low in
the digital swamps of Wikipedia
on the-- surprise, surprise--
entry for utopian socialism.
Now to be fair, it may be
that Utopia is considered
a socialist book because
at least some socialists,
trained as they are
for straightforward,
scientific accounts of political
economy and radical revolution,
cannot read a text for
metaphor and irony.
Being able to read for
subtlety takes a good deal
of liberal arts
training, like the kind
we offer here at Hillsdale.
Perhaps it's as simple as to
say they are just too literal
minded, lacking a literary
education in true wit.
Or maybe they're just
mentally drained from all
the pamphleteering.
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe.
I tend to think that it gets
them excited for some reason.
Being able to read for subtlety,
that skill not being there--
maybe it's just that
they have subtlety,
but they actually refuse
to read for subtlety
in a way that takes Utopia's
ironic and mocking presentation
of their own position
seriously because they're
more interested in the
political project of socialism
than being truthful about
what other people have said.
That is, they don't
mind lying to you.
That was Solzhenitsyn's big
point in The Gulag Archipelago.
Remember, Professor
John Grant, the head
of the politics
department here, came out
to Kirby a few years back.
The lie-- they want
to hold the lie.
And Solzhenitsyn was like,
you got to speak the truth.
Or perhaps they
simply can't bear
to be mocked, so they just
block out the subtle reasoning.
Maybe it's subconscious.
Another possible obstacle
to reading Utopia
wittily is that most socialists
think too little about politics
and think much more narrowly
about economic questions
concerning the
means of production.
They tend to deride political
and constitutional fixes
as merely bourgeois
institutions,
half measures, to be pitied.
They must be swept away by the
revolution as soon as possible.
That means they do
not consider rightly
nor respect the fact
that Thomas More is,
in fact, a proto-Republican.
He's a proto-Republican thinker.
That is, More's ironic
criticism of private property,
in the voice of
Raphael Hythloday,
is not the radical
attacks of socialists
on a widely distributed
and legally held
democratic system of private
property, generosity,
and equality, like we have or
strive to have here in the US.
Rather, More's teachings
on private property
are attempting to moderate the
radically oligarchic position
of the landed
aristocracy of England.
I'm reminded of
one of my teachers,
another Hillsdale professor, Dr.
Tom West, when he would lament
the lockup of federal
lands by the US
Senate and the Department
of Interior that
couldn't be accessed for
private property ownership
by the citizenry.
Instead, imagine this.
More was looking at an
unelected Senate, namely
the House of Lords, the
members of which personally
own the land and have permanent
claim to it in perpetuity
for their descendants
forever and ever, amen.
It's not surprising
that radical socialists
can't see More's attempt to
moderate the claims of property
ownership so that property
could be treated in a way more
in line with common
sense and natural reason,
changing the law to something
closer to what we have now.
But socialists probably
do see, at least,
that More is honoring
admirable qualities of at least
some socialists or
some accounts of what
we might call soft
socialism, for instance,
detachment from material goods.
We should be detached.
We can't take it with us.
You don't want your
things to own you.
You want to own your things.
That's very admirable.
Love of the poor, that's
very good, see Jesus.
And yes, ridicule for
the folly-filled idea
that you and your family have
a given plot of land by nature.
In other words,
the ideology behind
landed aristocracy, which
we Americans expressly
forbid in our Constitution,
in part because
of the witty, proto-Republican,
counsels of writers like More.
But socialists don't see these
subtle dynamics in Utopia
because those ironies
detail and serve
the purpose of weakening
the claims of nobility
and encouraging the civic
spiritedness of generosity
and friendship.
And a proper, witty, and
accurate reading of Utopia
does not support the socialists'
historical narratives
nor their radical
policy to abolish
all or most private property for
the sake of socialist control
of the means of production.
Socialists seem not to suspect
More's strong, yet subtle
mockery of their very dangerous
intellectual vices, their love
of monologues, of
having their way,
of living like kings
in their opinions,
unhampered by the messy details
of actual political reality.
It's true that More respects
the socialist character type.
Raphael Hythloday's first
name does mean healer of God.
Just so, the socialist
character type,
as an admirably ardent
desire for perfection--
that's commendable-- is
worth praising for a society
where no one suffers.
Never going to happen,
but, obviously, it's
something that theoretically
you would like to see.
We're all hoping for
heaven, for something
like that, where every
tear shall be wiped away,
and where Engels--
or as Engels put it,
where everyone holds,
quote, "The common
property of all
to be worked for the
common good of all."
Or as Matt Bell was
quoting earlier, heaven,
but you don't even need it.
It all sounds nice.
It sounds lovely.
Socialism does sound good.
Witty Sir Thomas More
was aware of just how
lovely socialism sounded.
But just as it takes a certain
sharp-sighted wit to see when
an offer is too good
to be true, likewise--
I just saw a billboard, driving
from the Detroit Airport
today--
free college.
That was all the billboard
said and some address.
You're like, probably not.
Something's up.
Hold on to your wallet.
Likewise, More seeks in
Utopia to train our own wit,
to see the difference between
a political order that
sounds good and
one that actually
looks good in reality,
one that is good and not
just good in theory.
That's why the proto-socialist
character of Raphael Hythloday
isn't just God's healer nor
simply a skilled speaker
in nonsense.
He has both names together
because nothing that is
is all bad nor, in this world
at least, all good in all
respects at all times.
This sort of double
vision, this ability
to see something admirable
in socialist impulses
while also realizing the
dangerous and tyrannical,
deeply tyrannical impulses
that lurk beneath them,
this sort of witty, wise habit
of looking at life and politics
to see what it is, what
you wish it could be,
and the difference between
prudential political
improvements and radically
dangerous, dangerously radical,
thoroughly stupid, and stupidly
thorough political change
is revealed in Utopia as the
difference between dialogue
and monologue, between
More and Hythloday,
and between what we might call
Republican wit and tyrannical
and socialist grundlichkeit.
And More's Utopia, centuries
before the full flowering
of socialism and
communism, offers
a deep meditation on
prudential politics
and a powerful and witty
critique of such thoroughgoing
tyrannies, the sort
that is enslaved
to a witless idea of
perfection into the sound
of their own monologic voices.
At the close of Utopia,
after a long tale
from Hythloday full of ironic
and conflicting statements
designed to help
the reader think
about politics and justice,
More's own character
thinks that the laws and
customs of the Utopians
seem very absurdly established.
But, he says, "Most of
all in that feature,
which is the
principle foundation
of their whole structure,
I mean their common life
and subsistence without
any exchange of money."
Utopia's lack of
customs and laws
protecting private
property and commerce
More emphasizes, quote, "utterly
overthrows all the nobility,"
taking from the
nobles that word.
If you take away private
property of all the people
of the commonwealth, the
commons, "you overthrow--
utterly overthrow all the
nobility, magnificence--"
that's a kingly term--
"splendor--" another
kingly-- "and majesty--"
another kingly term--
"which are, in the estimation
of the common people,
the true glories and ornaments
of the commonwealth."
The Latin here is more telling.
And forgive me--
[SPEAKING LATIN]
Thomas More is
carefully, wittily,
and subtly a champion of
democratic republicanism
in an age of monarchs
and monologues, a writer
responsible for a masterwork
of Western literature
full of Socratic irony
designed to educate
a free people for personal
virtue and self-government
by means of a city and
speech like that of Plato's
in the "Republic" or more
like Cicero's in the "De re
publica."
It was this man,
Thomas More, whom
Lenin, in one of history's
monumental ironies,
deigned to call comrade.
I imagine that the wily
and witty Sir Thomas
More, the statesman
who Shakespeare tells
us loved to be merry, would
have received this honor
if he were alive today with
a wry smile and his trademark
irony.
He might have said
something like this.
Thank you, comrades.
I had thought that the Union
of Soviet Socialist Republics
would have better left
me out in the cold,
but you have honored me in a
way no good man should ever
hope for.
[LAUGHTER]
You can make those
kinds of jokes all day
if you read Utopia as
many times as I have.
That's what it's designed
to do, fashion your wit,
shape your wit.
Now I'll stop monologuing and
start dialoguing with you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Thank you Dr. Mehan.
We now have time for Q&A. Please
make your way to the microphone
if you have a question.
AUDIENCE: I just
have short question.
I can't get to the microphone,
but I understand that Utopia
was written in Latin?
MATTHEW MEHAN: That's right.
AUDIENCE: And it is able
to be read in English?
MATTHEW MEHAN: Mhm.
Yeah.
There's a number
of translations.
There's ones free online.
There's a really excellent
translation that's actually
coming out from The Essential
Works of Thomas More
this January, which was put
together over the course of 20
years with a professor, Jerry
Wegemer, who I studied with,
but also his co-editor
is Dr. Stephen Smith
here at Hillsdale.
So it's actually--
that book's coming out
in January with the
best translation,
the best notes
that really explain
what is going on in this text
and all of More's major texts.
That's coming in January.
And for a mind of
this caliber who's
written this many classics and
has had this much influence,
this happens once
every 100 years.
So that's something to pay
attention to in January.
But that's the best translation.
I've seen it.
I've heckled over some of
its footnotes with Steve
a couple of times.
But that's coming
out in January.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: I think
of Marx and Engels--
AUDIENCE: Can you go
to the microphone, sir?
SPEAKER 2: Please make
your way to the microphone
if you have a question.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Not sure
if this is working.
MATTHEW MEHAN: The long walk.
We'll take one while
he's getting there.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for your talk today.
I remember-- I'm getting
to the point in my life
where I'm thinking, long ago,
when the dinosaurs were young,
I used to tell my daughter.
I remember-- and this is more
of a current cultural thing,
but I think it's tangentially
related to Thomas More,
that we had a richness
of comedy in our culture,
from broad slapstick to
incisive, intellectual wit.
And it seems like
today, there's no humor
because the
socialists have taken
over the mechanisms of comedy.
And through this
PC nonsense, which
is nothing more than an
intellectual and a humor
straitjacket, is--
comedy's not funny.
It's either
scatological, or it's
just dreadfully morbid,
and dull, and malicious.
I just wanted to comment
from Thomas More to this.
Thank you.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
There are comics,
I think, oftentimes
some really excellent
wit is wasted
on scatological material,
some brilliant people who
decide to go hide in some filth
that is sort of not really
fit for dignified enjoyment.
So there's that problem.
I think there is
still wit out there.
It's oftentimes
submerged in some filth.
But you do see some rebellion.
And the comics and the comedians
are sort of fighting back,
even the director of
the latest Joker movie.
In protest, Joker is actually
a silent, grundlichkeit-type
film.
It's this ponderous,
dark, brooding thing.
He's a comic director.
But he said, I can't
do comedy for now.
So you're just going
to have to deal
with that, almost like a
protest, a sort of laughter
strike.
So I don't know if the
clowns are going to save us,
but there is sort of
some tomfoolery that's
gaining steam, I think.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
If I think of the inspiration
for Marx and Engels,
communism coming from
the sweatshops of England
in the 1820s, '30s,
'40s, and '50s,
where does Thomas More
get his inspiration
from for writing about
socialism the way he did?
MATTHEW MEHAN: Good question.
So the enclosure movement is
actually featured and discussed
in book one of the dialogue.
And for him, he's very
upset with the nobility
making property right
claims, evicting
peasants who've lived
in the same family
home for 1,000 years.
But because it wasn't
on a piece of paper
and it wasn't enforced
by the House of Lords,
the common people's common
wealth, their property,
their homes, were
judged worthless.
So that gets him thinking
about radical claims
to property ownership
of the lords.
So he's taking aim
at the lords who've
kicked all these people off
in order to make sheep folds.
But what's happened is
they've lost their homes,
so they can't farm.
And they wind up taking to
the streets, turning to crime.
And hangings spike
thousands of percent.
It's just a bloodbath.
Every day, they're
hanging people.
So More is responding to that.
But if you don't
pay attention, you
go, oh, look, he's mad
at private property.
No.
He loves private property.
He thinks it's been
violated by the nobility.
A specious private
property claim of the elite
has robbed all of the peasants
of their commonly held homes
for 1,000 years.
AUDIENCE: So I've not
read the Utopia yet
or Plato's "Republic."
I've just begun reading
The Gulag Archipelago,
but I have read quite a
majority of Plato's "Timaeus
and Critias," which tells the
story of Atlantis, which is--
the usual story we've
all heard some version of
is that it was a
utopia-type paradise that
fell because it turned to
decadence and just filth,
and was, of course, destroyed
in a tsunami or a flood.
That's the very
end of the story.
But also, the moral, I guess,
and social aspect or lesson
of the story was that a
utopia in the paradise sense,
at least if you're talking
about a government or socialism,
either one of any
sort, is that it's
ultimately unattainable
and uncreatable because it
falls apart and is badly
managed so much that there's
nothing you can do with it.
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So the question
is, so in this way,
are the two stories of
Atlantis and Utopia, is that--
am I accurate about
the similarity?
And what seems to be
the goal of socialism?
When you ask the socialists,
they have no vision.
So what is their coherent plan?
And is that a
correct similarity?
MATTHEW MEHAN: That was
a lot of grundlichkeit
for an awesome question.
[LAUGHTER]
You're absolutely right to see--
Critias, he says,
I've got this place
I'm going to tell you about
that seems very strange,
but every word of it's true.
So it's very much
Raphael Hythloday--
I swear, no place exists.
Utopia exists.
Sure, buddy.
He's a traveler,
kind of sketchy.
And he also says it was his
90-year-old grandfather who
told it to him
when he was eight.
So you're like, what, really?
You're going to have a
detailed political program
from that exchange?
So it's that same dubious I've
got a perfect ideal that's
very questionable.
So yeah, I think
More's definitely--
he translated
Plato's "Republic,"
I think, twice, and definitely
read a number of his dialogues,
to try to think deeply
about constitutionalism,
politics, Republican government.
And Utopia is, in
part, a product
of a very sustained study
of his own of Plato.
So you're totally right there.
That's a good catch.
And you're spot on.
What do they want?
I think More's got their
number in Raphael Hythloday.
What he really wants is
everyone to praise him,
everyone to say,
you're a genius,
everyone to more or less put
him up, pay for him, and say,
yeah, this guy's brilliant.
He's got a great plan.
Hopefully one day we can do it,
but let's give him some power.
Let's have him rule--
libido dominandi, the desire
to dominate other people.
Gnosticism-- I've got
a secret teaching.
It's really hard to
explain, and you don't
understand-- it's science.
It's history.
It's complicated.
Just give me all your
property, please.
[LAUGHTER]
I really think it gets down to
those kinds of simple, really
dangerous desires.
But they're under a giant
just smokescreen, yes, of--
but pink smoke, and green
smoke, and glitter, and bombs.
And then they fall
for the image-- no,
I'm really doing
this good thing.
SPEAKER 2: We have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: I'll ask
you a simple question.
Do you think socialism
has ever been achieved?
It sounds to me it's a fantasy
and remains a fantasy, as far
as any advanced society.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Do I think
it's ever been achieved?
AUDIENCE: Correct.
MATTHEW MEHAN: No.
No.
If achievement is a
one-minute sentiment
of a number of people with a
document in a room, then sure.
I'm sure it's been
achieved a number of times.
But no, we've never
had a working state
that's actually been
socialistic in the promise.
It's always been an
apparent socialism.
That's the kind of
double vision you need.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
[INAUDIBLE] a retort?
MATTHEW MEHAN: Oh, please.
AUDIENCE: I agree with you.
Because what happens,
there's always a small number
controlling a massive number,
whether it's a monarchy
or whatever.
It seems to come down to that.
And socialism is
another variety of that.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Agree.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
MATTHEW MEHAN: All right.
[APPLAUSE]